Speaker 1: An insanely sweaty Donald Trump
has delivered a visibly confused statement
on immigration.
I guess this is his campaign.
You know, for a guy who said Biden's a loser
for running a campaign from his basement,
even though Trump lost to the guy running
a campaign from his basement.
TRUMP Now, I guess this is his campaign putting
to get filming in a very hot room where he's
sweating and talking about issues he doesn't
understand.
Here is Trump's latest statement put out yesterday
about immigration.
Speaker 2: Far more illegal immigration.
Speaker 1: And that that volume is humiliatingly
low.
Here we go.
Let's let's start it over.
Speaker 2: Far more illegal immigrants have
entered the United States in the last two
years than at any time in American history
and by a massive margin.
Speaker 1: Now, if that is true.
What Trump is talking about is we've got more
people now.
If you're catching them, aren't you doing
a good job as far as Trump is concerned?
Hmm.
Confusing.
Speaker 2: We've never seen anything like
it.
Our country is under invasion.
Speaker 1: Nothing has dramatically changed
on immigration since Trump left and Biden
came in.
Other than there was a temporary slowdown
on movement of people due to the pandemic,
and that has eased.
But policy wise, almost nothing has changed.
Speaker 2: Days ago, 16,000 illegal aliens
were encountered crossing the border in a
single 48 hour period.
Speaker 1: Now, understand, by the way, the
jump cuts, because Trump can't string together
more than a sentence at a time are bizarre.
Remember what Trump means by encountered is
apprehended.
Apprehended.
That sounds like the Border Patrol under Biden
is doing a pretty good job by Trump's own
standards.
Speaker 2: A colossal migrant caravan recently
poured across the Rio Grande and into the
streets of El Paso, Texas, and the people
and the police didn't know what to do about
it.
It is truly a massive invasion.
Any form of amnesty now would be a catastrophe.
It rewards Joe Biden's lawlessness and it
rewards the criminal cartels, and it rewards
everyone who has broken the laws of our nation.
Speaker 1: And again, the first priority on
amnesty is people who have not broken the
law.
Kids, individuals who were brought here when
they were legally minors.
We're talking about DOCA.
It's low hanging fruit.
We should deal with it.
We could deal with it.
They don't want to do it.
Speaker 2: Because they've never done anything
to our country like they're doing right now.
Our country is being poisoned.
Remember, our border is not open because.
Speaker 1: By the way, dehumanizing language,
people are poisoning the country.
They are so filthy that they are.
It's it's a poison.
Speaker 2: Insufficient resources or legal
authorities.
Our border is open because Joe Biden has ordered
it to be opened.
Speaker 1: Understand that there is no such
policy that Biden has enacted because.
Speaker 2: Biden has broken the law and turn
it into shreds.
He has shredded our system and he's destroying
our country.
Biden inherited a flawless deportation system
that was working like never before in our
history.
We never did so well on the border as we were
doing just a short time ago.
Speaker 1: And now understand that the deportation
system Trump's talking about is the use of
Title 42 to more quickly deport people.
That is on the basis of COVID being a global
emergency.
Trump wants you to believe COVID wasn't really
a big deal and all these red state governors
were right to do nothing about it.
But it was also such a big deal that you needed
an expedited removal process for migrants.
Wait, how can both be true?
Was COVID an emergency or was it not Trump
administration?
Speaker 2: Giving Biden more resources will
simply translate to even more releases because
that's really what they have in mind.
Speaker 1: All right.
So none of this is true.
And again, for a guy who ridiculed Biden for
campaigning from his basement, Trump's campaign
in the 5 to 6 weeks since he announced has
been to sit in a hot room and record sweaty
videos.
It doesn't sound particularly good.
And by the way, Biden's polling was much better
than Trump seems to be right now.
We'll have this clip on our Instagram, which
you can find at David Pakman.
Show Wild and Wacky Stuff.